y
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
cuando era pequeña veía como mi mamá
intercambiaba con sus vecinas lo que
ellas llamaban o quitas de yogur
tenían que cuidar les tenían que darles
leche lavar les taparles y se ponían muy
contenta al ver cómo con el paso de los
días los coquitos de yogur iban
creciendo
la verdad nunca me pregunte de dónde
venían ni que eran los coquitos de yogur
que hacían mi desayuno
y tampoco me imaginé que eso que mi mamá
hacía diariamente era lo que yo me iba a
dedicar cuando grande
estudié tres años de maestría casi cinco
años de doctorado y hoy oficialmente
puedo decir que soy cuidadora de
coquitos de yogur
mi nombre es linda huamán y soy
microbióloga
así como en el caso de los coquitos de
yogur que ahora sé que son
microorganismos
los científicos usamos diferentes
cubitos a los cuales también nos
cuidamos les damos de comer y los
conocemos también al punto de que
podemos modificarlos para que no
solamente produzcan yogur cerveza
sino también diferentes compuestos de
utilidad como vacunas compuestos
farmacéuticos biocombustibles
es a eso lo que llamamos biotecnología
al uso de organismos vivos para la
obtención de diferentes productos
la biotecnología como hoy la conocemos
en gran medida le debe su desarrollo al
sexo que tienen estos poquitos
por diferentes mecanismos
este sexo al que yo lo estoy llamando de
esta forma no es otra cosa sino la
transferencia de material genético que
ocurre entre ellos y esta capacidad que
tienen ellos de transferir su
información genética nosotros la hemos
aprendido muy bien los científicos la
hemos observado y la adaptamos para
usarla como una herramienta que nos
permite programar a los microorganismos
y de esa forma convertirlos en pequeñas
fábricas entonces si el sexo de los
coquitos nos ha permitido en gran medida
el desarrollo de la biotecnología
y esta transferencia o sexo de cuchillos
nos enseña muchísimo acerca de
diversidad y de igualdad y es justamente
sobre eso lo que les voy a hablar en los
siguientes minutos
algunos de los mecanismos por los cuales
estos bichitos se transfieren
información genética se dan porque ellos
van por la vida interactuando con
diferentes microorganismos y ahora les
voy a contar cuáles son los mecanismos
que les permiten traspasar se esta
información la primera se conoce como
conjugación
la segunda transformación y la tercera
transducción
quiero contarles además
que en el caso de los humanos el sexo
es el motor que nos permite ser diversos
nosotros somos el resultado de la mitad
de la mezcla de papá y de mamá y por eso
somos así diferentes en el caso de las
bacterias en cambio esto no sucede
ellas no tienen la reproducción como en
el caso de los humanos entonces lo que
hace es que una bacteria se alarga se
divide y produce dos bacterias y esto
tiene consecuencias a nivel genético la
principal es que todas las bacterias son
clones la bacteria mama y la bacteria
hija son idénticas
entonces de dónde viene la diversidad
porque sabemos hoy en día que hay
muchísimos tipos muchísimas especies de
bacterias
entonces hay bacterias alrededor del
mundo diversas tenían que encontrar
alguna forma por la cual es hacerse
diferentes unas de otras y es ahí en
donde entran en juego estos mecanismos
por ejemplo la conjugación es el
mecanismo por el cual una bacteria
literalmente le inyecta material
genético a otra como si se tratara de
una jeringuilla
y entonces ahora esta bacteria tiene una
información nueva el segundo mecanismo
es la transformación que es una
capacidad natural que tienen algunas
bacterias de comerse pedacitos de adn
como el que es dejado por una bacteria
tras su muerte
y de esa forma también adquieren nueva
información y el tercer mecanismo es la
transducción este mecanismo de adquirir
nueva información genética está mediada
por un virus un bacteriófago que le
inyecta material genético nuevo y de
esta forma luego infecta otra bacteria y
va transfiriendo diferente información
nuestros ancestros que son las bacterias
continúan ávidamente intercambiando
material genético de la manera más
promiscua por estos tres mecanismos que
les acabo de mencionar ellas no son
exigentes van por la vida tomando
diferentes fragmentos pedacitos de adn
incluso en lugares muy extraños ahora
mismo dentro de cada uno de nosotros
tenemos bacterias teniendo sexo
intercambiando información genética
dado que ellas reconocen esto como una
ventaja abraza en la diversidad y se
transforman tomando lo mejor que puede
ofrecer otro microorganismo
esta transferencia de material genético
en las bacterias les permite a ellas
cambiar
hagamos una pausa aquí y pensemos que a
veces los seres humanos
nos creemos falsamente superiores más
evolucionados algunos inclusive decimos
que somos de una raza más pura
y es más o menos frecuente escuchar por
ahí cuida con quién te juntas cuida con
quien compartes tus genes le hemos dado
al mestizaje una connotación negativa
y en el caso de las bacterias que son
los organismos vivos más exitosos del
planeta este discurso de pureza parece
no importarles iván por todos lados
tomando información de diferentes
organismos sin importarles sin
discriminar
porque este sexo o transferencia del
material genético les permite a ellas
adaptarse les permite sobrevivir
si esa información que otro micrones no
me da y me sirve lo tomó por que
discriminaría porque tengo que mirar de
quien viene
actualmente junto con mi grupo de
investigación en el centro de
investigación biomédica de la
universidad de lo que estoy haciendo es
utilizar este microorganismo que se
llama sacaron mi celular y es una
levadura prima hermana de la que hace
cerveza
lo que estoy intentando es justo usar
estos tres diferentes mecanismos que las
bacterias se usan para tener sexo yo los
uso como herramientas para poder
modificar a esta levadura
lo que yo quiero hacer es que ya aprenda
a tener la capacidad de producir wood
irato un compuesto que tiene múltiples
beneficios en la salud
así como yo que utilizo estos mecanismos
para transformar a sacar mis es volar de
otros científicos alrededor del mundo
están usando también la capacidad de
tener sexo de los microorganismos para
producir diferentes compuestos algunos
ya se han producido por ejemplo bio
sensores para detectar contaminantes en
el ambiente biocombustibles plástico
biodegradable incluso ya se ha
modificado microorganismos para actúen
como bio sensores detecten tumores y
también los ataques
y finalmente quiero invitarlos a pensar
que de alguna forma todos hacemos
biotecnología en casa cuando hacemos
chicha cuando hacemos pan cuando hacemos
yogurt de coquitos
luego de estudiar con profundidad a
estos pequeños seres he aprendido que
ellos
son el mejor ejemplo de lo que significa
abrazar la diversidad
tomar lo mejor que el otro me tiene que
ofrecer no discriminar
me enseña que el mestizaje es bueno
porque me cambia me adapta
finalmente luego de varios años como
cuidadora de poquitos
les puedo decir con certeza absoluta que
sin temas de género me preguntan si
preferiría ser hombre o mujer les digo
con seguridad absoluta que yo preferiría
ser una bacteria muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
u